parce que en fait il est fatigué
dépressif mais c'est vrai qu'il ne s'est
jamais remis du fameux médicament qu'il
avait pris contre le paludisme et ça lui
a causé des effets dramatiques et c'est
quoi cette histoire si j'ai jamais
compris c'est une histoire de fou ça
c'est une histoire de fou alors il était
au Congo et avant d'aller au Congo comme
dans beaucoup de pays d'Afrique vous
prenez des médicaments contre le
paludisme et il avait pris un médicament
qui commence par l je donne le nom ou
pas non voilà mais par elle oui c'est un
médicament comprenez à l'époque qui
maintenant n'est pas distribué et la
Bible c'est vous êtes presque et en fait
ce médicament une fois sur 10000 causent
des dommages neurologiques graves dont
on ne se remet jamais et il ne s'est
jamais remis de ça il a même des
détresse ça peut pousser au suicide non
des angoisses terribles terribles sa vie
est dévastée depuis l'ordre ça c'est
quelqu'un de fragile et bien aujourd'hui
il est épuisé et il ne sait pas quand il
pourra reprendre sa tournée voilà il est
annulé totalement incroyable c'est un
médicament obligatoire quand on allait
en Afrique
du médicament et c'est vrai que ça peut
causer des ravages angoisses suicide lui
il avait appelé ça décompensation
psychique c'est-à-dire que en fait ils
ne se sent pas capable d'assumer sa vie
tout simplement à cause du médicament
alors certains ont dit beaucoup de
choses il y a eu beaucoup de fantasmes
mais tous ces troubles initiaux viennent
de là sur un terrain fragile mais c'est
ça le drame c'est ça oui parler de
penser suicidaire il y a un moment il a
fait toute une tournée autour de ça
promo où il parlait de sa dépression et
après il est revenu et les journalistes
avaient interdiction de lui parler de ça
parce que ça allait pas déjà depuis
plusieurs mois donc il savait que ça
allait s'arrêter la tournée il avait été
rapatriés d'urgence en 2015 au Congo il
avait pas fini non c'est pas passé
depuis non non ça peut durer toute la
ville c'est des effets secondaires qui
sont terribles